[Music]
do you guys know who tycho ytt is of
course yeah yeah he's from new zealand
was taika named after that taika yeah
was he oh really named after him
you know what titi is that's his last
name dt so you guys named taika after
tekoytd like in honor of him no not an
honorable like we liked his name but
that was a really cool name yeah and
then so in the name list that we came up
with like taiko just stood out so it was
like oh let's see his ticket too taco
ytt has been arrested for killing
a family of seven that's a lot of people
humor
i'ma change his name to uh
christopher nolan
another good director
ted
steven spielberg can't trip him up i
think it's the name of a japanese
emperor or something too yeah that's
what we looked it up it's a it's a name
that exists
in like i think like 37 languages wow
wow
so if you could ditch this one you could
probably say it's because of some other
reason yeah i just can't believe you'd
give up on that name so fast
because i was lying
i was lying actually yep yep that was a
relief huh i didn't change it yet so
tucker ytt had a bit of a slip up during
a conversation with natalie portman
about his upcoming gig he is directing a
star wars film
so he offered her he's like hey how'd
you like to be in a star wars movie
which is kind of wild because
he's like
hypothetically natalie portman was the
star of the first three
technically second first the first after
the third the first three yeah but
that's like when the cg got good three
that is what it got really good in three
i missed the [ __ ] old school style of
like just puppets like yeah props and
just set design so you're talking about
episode four five and six yeah the first
three yeah because that's when that's
when the cgi came in for one two and
three i don't like cgi dude jar jar
binks was wasn't a puppet jar jar
i'm a fan of jar jar binks by the way
steve's gonna punch you in the [ __ ]
face too and you know what i what else
woke up brother
i missed the 70s idea of what the future
is that's what star wars is
is that [ __ ] that's because back then
the future had promise and hope
yeah now it's all fun
they made blade runner around that time
like the 80s right a lot of dirt a lot
of desert yeah the future is a lot of
desert
but it's their idea of the tech because
then now like if you see all the cg and
[ __ ] it actually looks like the future
because the 20 000's idea of the future
wait so you think that star wars is
supposed to look like the future but
then stuff but if you watch star wars
like the millennium falcon looks like
[ __ ] like all the tech and stuff all the
buttons
just like little green
that's why i like it no but star trek
was the one that was trying to look like
the future future where it's all like
clean and nice and [ __ ] the new star
trek movies are tight though they're
pretty tight hey the old ones were you
like you like the new star trek movies
you ever seen rather khan are you
talking about the new structure no no
the star trek two the wrath of con the
great one of the greatest sci-fi movies
ever
yeah that's my favorite star trek movie
but the new one the first star trek the
first one was really good this pine was
[ __ ] bomb i like the new ones they're
cool i don't think i watched the third
one but i definitely watched the first
two give me three right the first one
was really good the second one was not
as good the third one was not as good as
are the jj abrams ones yeah yeah i like
the first two on those i like the
unmotivated lens flares so what do you
got what are your guys takes on the on
the uh well on the prequels cause like
natalie portman she took it in stride
she was like yo i've been in a star wars
movie dude what the [ __ ] are you talking
about and he forgot yeah he forgot
because i think that happens to some
people because the there was fans of the
og star wars right and then there was
the prequels which i think mostly our
generation absorbed the prequels the
our parents all thought was [ __ ] wack
i thought it was whack i
liked it but it was because anakin star
walker sorry skywalker [ __ ] yeah but i
was i was a kid i liked it as a kid
because i remember i remember going to a
movie theater with my mom to watch it as
like at like seven years old and like
seeing that on the big screen was
[ __ ] cool or i remember the idea of
going to like uh was it mcdonald's happy
meals they had the pod racers yeah you
had that they had that toy that opened
up and there's like a whole little thing
like the lightsaber fight the population
game you play the game the pod racer
game i would only be able to demo in the
[ __ ] game stores you know when you go
to games i just played there but dude i
thought i was a [ __ ] jedi because i
was like i'm going 600 miles an hour but
i am in control
that's impossible i feel like this is
how you can tell like how just being a
couple years apart can [ __ ] it all up
with the memories because then when
you're a teenager you're just too
[ __ ] cool
and then when you were a kid you
remember the og star wars [ __ ] and
you're like that was the dope stuff and
then when you're a kid and you're a
stupid little kid and you like anakin
skywalker and [ __ ] and all that stuff
and then you write you think that's cool
the teenagers look at you and say you're
lamenting i was a teenager though but i
was like 13. so i remember watching the
third episode in theaters and i thought
that that was a little weird like i
laughed at the part where anakin gets
set on fire because it just seemed goofy
to me but up until that point i think
one yeah i hate you
it was very dramatic you were my brother
but one and two i liked one and two when
i saw them in theaters i remember seeing
in theaters but now looking back at it i
was like oh that was a little weird but
you don't like this new generation of
diversity and women empowerment princess
leia was in power [ __ ] why does
everyone say that [ __ ] it's so funny
nobody watched the first star wars
movies plus what's up what's the black
dude in the most recent one huh
i felt like the entire arc was about to
be about him and then the second movie
they just ditched him
they [ __ ] him so hard interesting
character arc that we got the most
interesting character arc in that oh
yeah and that whole series yeah so what
happened to the diversity there like was
it like the force awakens because i was
like okay it's kind of a reboot of the
other ones that i've seen but like i
remember being a kid and seeing in
theaters okay so there's like something
like five year old here that's gonna
star movies in the last 20 years in my
opinion rogue one
period and that wasn't even like the
episodic arc that was like a side story
to fill in some information and make
some money i want to see more star wars
movies that are like just war movies in
space like yeah like when they were
going in on the [ __ ] you want to get
back to the wars and get away from the
start yeah yeah don't get me started on
obi-wan kenobi hey let's talk about i'll
be making him you want to go do you want
to talk about obi-wan okay so i think my
problem is i'm just such a fan he's my
literally favorite character in all
stars yes likewise same way
yes right so more of a window guy oh
[ __ ] you bro
[Laughter]
jar jar beaks kind of guy dude
apparently there's a lot of jar jar i
love going around i thought johnny was
saying although are you really saying
that or is it because of what ahmed best
went through because ahmed best like
almost killed himself which is so sad is
that the best guy who played jar jar
yeah he played jared he almost killed
himself he was such a genuine because
everyone hated jar jar they gave him so
much and like he's he was expecting
because like you know you're filming
this movie and like you got george lucas
who's like one of the greatest legends
ever in filmmaking they even accused
that of racism because they're saying
like jar jar was representing minorities
and that too yeah so so that's going on
but you got george pumping you up
gassing you the [ __ ] up you got liam
neeson laughing at your bits on set so
you're thinking like this is going to be
tight for me right now the movie comes
out everyone shits completely on one
person and it was him right and so he
took on all that scapegoat but the thing
is kids love jar jar though right it was
just the [ __ ]
fans and the [ __ ] geeks hated jar jar
yeah the people who were like too old
for the movies
obviously i don't [ __ ] have a poster
of jar jar in my room or anything i'm
just saying i think he was like
memorable he was lovable dude he was
like [ __ ] groot i'm just asking
because because like obi wan obi-wan was
my favorite who plays obi-wan oh you and
mcgregor and alan
guinness mcgregor
here you're at alexander said about star
wars like bro
bro i did so many [ __ ] cool things in
my career and all i remember before is
being [ __ ] this like space samurai
yeah
look at charles dude look at charlton
heston right he did so many movies he's
the most like a credit actor for his
time he's remembered mostly for a meme
where he's kissing a monkey okay well i
mean with the apes is pretty iconic
though kissing a monkey damn dirty you
blew it all up the monkey kissing moment
that's what he's known for she was
pretty fine though you know
calling mcbee that's all i got to say
uh but yes obi-wan kenobi i thought i
was so excited for this epic six episode
reboot yes they're doing like that in
between period you know what i mean
after episode three before episode four
type [ __ ] they're trying to connect
everything and then they do they choose
to do this whole bit where it's like
about leia when she's a kid which i'm
okay with the actress i'm not gonna say
anything you know she's a kid i thought
it was cute and all that stuff i'm okay
with
but i just felt like if you're gonna
take that time
you said that i just felt like you're
gonna take that time and you're gonna
bring back two of the most legendary and
iconic stories or people aka literally
darth vader and obi-wan and they come
back and they brought hayden christensen
back in order to do this
it just felt underwhelming it felt like
they were taking like what could have
been the satisfaction that that die hard
star wars star wars fans from two
different generations
could come to the table and like be like
yo we're [ __ ] about this and they
like kind of like just went somewhere
else with it they tried to fill in some
other gaps and they didn't do it justice
in a certain way as a fan where i wanted
to see obi-wan and darth vader just have
either more depth or more and i think
you got the whole thing right yeah i did
yeah so they did have i mean they had it
but yeah
maybe they just had they put too much
focus on like the the story of like leia
and all that so that obi-wan's entire
mission was again spoiler alert for
anybody who didn't watch it for sure but
she he just kind of goes around it's
really just more about her and like
figuring out and making sure that she's
just laying a little spoiler dumb [ __ ]
it's been a while though no it just it
just felt like it wasn't where i wanted
it to be it's all and i get that i'm not
gonna hate on it i'm just saying like oh
man it was like obviously like full
story but they made it more about like
in my opinion that had problems like i
totally know what you're talking about
but i think my problem is i'm so biased
because i like the character so much i
was just like happy to hang with them
again sure i still watched it yeah yeah
yeah but and the way that they they
closed it out i think episodes five and
six were dope because they closed it out
like focusing on the relationship
between the two like with anakin invader
and like that even that mask open moment
was tight right that was that you know
that was lifted apparently from another
part which i hadn't seen in star wars
what's lucas's involvement in all these
new ones like storytelling or anything
because i think that's probably what
[ __ ] it up he gets a chance there's
like a bud yeah
so he's on set he was on set but he's
not part of the creative house he's just
there to eat the catering and hang out
with his friends if they did i do enjoy
that they busted uh another val kilmer
with uh with taco maverick and they did
that with james earl jones's voice yeah
and then brought back him
by the way it's flawless it's so good it
sounds like james jones i thought it was
like another voice actor who just was
mimicking but then i was like luckily we
had just did a whole bit on [ __ ] val
kilmer yeah talking about how they aid
his voice so i had to look it up because
i was like this is too [ __ ] good wait
they ai had his voice on [ __ ] james
jones oh val kilmer on
no because they play into that character
if you watch it they play into like that
character having this certain sickness
or whatever and i was just like oh [ __ ]
this is crazy like you know uh they
[ __ ] made it work so valve's been in
so much stuff like james jones they
synthesized it and they created an ai
that helps to just plug and play like
whatever dialogue they want and it's
like yeah very little though like most
of it it was interesting how they did it
without too much spoiling but then like
he would type on the computer
and then he would communicate with him
like that yeah that's because he
literally can't speak really so james
earl jones um you know the voice of
darth vader yeah he
had nothing to do with obi-wan at all
but they obviously pay him a royalty
because they're using like an
amalgamation of all of his voices like
from the past performances and like just
splicing them together to create this ai
that's actually making the voice like
fill in the blanks it's crazy it's kind
of like how they do defects they
actually take an actor who looks similar
to the actor that you're trying to make
and then they put they put project that
on top
but they need that they need that base
layer of like similarity in order and
then they put this thing in he's like i
could eat a peach for hours
[Laughter]
you know how there's a
star wars fans right yeah and then
there's star trek fans right so so and
then there's a lot of people battling
between the two but i'm so under i'm so
underground i'm a star gate fan dude
circus target sg-1
that's the guy who does the voice acting
from god of war
uh right oh oh you're talking about teal
teal the one that looks like he's always
smelling [ __ ] the guy with the the
symbol on his head yeah he's good great
voice actor yeah he's got that deep
voice and he plays the main main
character aka kratos in god one he got
an award for it because he was so
[ __ ] good yeah he's really good yeah
he always looks like he smells some [ __ ]
he could have been in my opinion he
could have been vin diesel
yeah because he has that [ __ ] voice
and that presence and [ __ ] but he just
got stuck on a shitty tv show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you